there is a difference between Bitcoin
and crypto that's really important 21
million that's really important there
will never be because we know there's a
hard cap that's really important you you
know you were talking earlier about
printing money with gold we never really
know how much gold there is there always
more gold there not there always more to
be frowned so I want Bitcoin I want
Bitcoin because when the government came
and said if you don't take our if you
don't take our mandatory medicines you
don't take our injections then we're
going to freeze your bank accounts I
need to know that I have money that's
immune compation but money because I pay
people in Bitcoin and they pay me in
Bitcoin so I'm literally running a
business in Bitcoin